[Music]
let's talk about the the shadow side of
puzzles so it drove them crazy yeah
there is a there is a shadow sign i see
a bullet here tackling a logic puzzle
that literally drives people insane and
has spawned 100 philosophy papers please
tell me more about this
oh yes this is called the sleeping
beauty problem and it's a cousin of the
monty hall problem do you know the monty
hall from i don't i don't know that
either maybe you could maybe you could
explain so the monty hall problem is a
very famous puzzle very controversial
and it was popularized by marilyn vos
savant i don't know if you've had her on
the show this woman who says she's got
the highest iq ever so she wrote a
column in parade magazine no comment on
why the smartest woman was writing a
grade magazine
column
because she's smarter than me so she
would slam me but anyway
the problem she popularized was this
suppose you're on a game show
and you're given a choice of three doors
behind one door is a car and behind the
other two doors are goats
assuming you want the car and not the
goats so your goal is to pick the door
with the car so you pick door number one
and the host he knows what's behind all
three doors and he says
well i'm going to open door number three
before i answer whether you got it right
i'm opening door number three which and
behind that door is a goat then he says
to you
so you want to switch you want to pick
door number two instead
oh
my gut
and most people's gut is like now why
why would it matter it's like 50 50
right but it's not
oh you should switch you should switch
okay so this is
this is uh yeah this is a better
question for my brother who has a lot of
statistics and mathematical
uh training and inclination okay so i
would not have no i would not have
passed i would have failed that test
most people do because it's so
counterintuitive and that's another big
theme of puzzles i think is that don't
trust your gut i am very wary of my gut
i feel my gut as an idiot especially
when it comes to
matters of probability so yes you should
switch and when she wrote this she got
hundreds of condescending letters from
mathematicians saying you're an idiot
but she's right you should switch and
you can look it up why but basically
instead of your initial odds of one to
three you have a two out of three
probability of getting the car because
monty didn't just pick a random door he
knew what was behind all three doors and
he picked a goat so then it narrows it
down but anyway this sleeping beauty
problem i mean i'm not i'm not going to
say it because it's super complicated
and it'll put you to sleep but it is
it has it's in the book
but it has caused as you say 100
philosophy papers and i love it because
this is one of the puzzles
that has no correct people are still
debating what the answer is is the
answer two out of three or is it one out
of two or something else
so i love a puzzle that that cannot be
solved and actually as part of the book
i commissioned what i believe is the
hardest puzzle in the history of the
world and it cannot be solved because
you cannot solve it by the time the
universe runs out of energy it's a
mechanical puzzle where it's got a metal
rod inside a tower and in the tower
there are all these pegs and you have to
turn the pegs to remove the
the metal rod but you have to turn the
pegs many times many many times
1.2 decillion times which is one with 33
digits
yeah so it is literally if you do one
every second every nanosecond the
universe will will end and i love that i
love that
so what what was the impetus for
for creating this puzzle and this is
jacob's ladder am i right yes exactly
okay
a few reasons i loved it one
it's part of a genre called generation
puzzles where you pass them down from
generation to generation because no one
person can solve it so i love this idea
of connecting generations and
and thinking of you mentioned 80 000
hours
and they talk a lot that's the effect of
altruism movement they talk a lot about
the far future and our our like you know
14th great grandkids and so this is sort
of a way to connect with that
one of the great japanese puzzle makers
he was called the godfather of sudoku
and he summarized puzzles and much of
life with three symbols the question
mark
the forward arrow the exclamation point
you arrive you're baffled forward hour
arrow is the struggle the you know the
wrestling with the and then the
exclamation point is the revelation and
he said this is very zen he said you
have to embrace the arrow you have to
learn to love
the solving because you're not always
going to get to the exclamation point so
this is the ultimate arrow this arrow is
goes on until
you you know to the end of the universe
so i love that i love that and it's also
i love it because it's kind of like a
ritual that i can do a little meditative
ritual so yeah i am i am a big there's
only one in the world jacob's ladder
where is it located i'm looking at it
right now it's the left of my desk it's
taunting me
i mean the guy he's a brilliant puzzle
maker oscar van de venter was the one
who designed it so he's going to release
the plans on the internet so you can 3d
print one yourself so it will be
available
you